If you're running a
2D game on mobile,
chances are that you
care a great deal
about rendering performance.
But one of your
biggest perf problems
could be coming from a weird
combination of alpha blending,
overdraw, and how you
create your texture atlases.
But let's start at the top.
Modern 2D games are
awash in awesome graphics
to create the visuals
for their scene.
But when you start
to break it down,
you realize that
drawing your environment
is actually a complex
dance involving
drawing multiple
layers of graphics.
For example, the background
layer, ground info,
sprites, and, finally, UI data.
Every now and
again, though, we'll
see some weird
additional layers pop up
that don't end up contributing
to the final scene.
In reality, these
extra draws create
a lot of wasted
performance, which
is a scarce resource
on mobile platforms.
There's really two
ways to look at how
you render your
graphics and your scene.
The first is back to front
order and generally involves
drawing geometry
farther from your camera
before geometry that's
closer to your camera.
The end result is the last drawn
pixel with the closest distance
to the camera.
Front to back order,
on the other hand,
draws images closer
to the camera
first and then progressively
gets further away.
Although the rendering order
of both of these techniques
produces the same
final pixel color,
back to front
produces 2x more work
that doesn't contribute
to the final scene,
or, as we prefer to
call it, overdraw.
The reason for the
performance difference
has to do with how modern
graphics APIs work.
You see OpenGL ES and all
of its desktop brethren
support a mode called
depth testing, which
allows you to avoid
processing any pixels that
don't contribute
to the final image.
Here's how it works.
When a pixel on the screen is
updated with color information,
we also store its
depth from the camera.
When the rasterizer attempts
to draw another pixel
at that location, we first test
the depth of the incoming pixel
against that of
the existing pixel.
If it's farther from the
camera, then we discard it,
saving cycles
since we don't have
to compute any of the color.
Now if the incoming pixel
is closer to the camera,
on the other hand,
then we continue on,
compute its color
information, and write it back
to the color buffer.
Overdraw is a term
used to describe
how many times a
pixel on the screen
has been redrawn
in a single frame.
For example, drawing a large
background image like this,
and then drawing a box on top of
it, another one on top of that,
and then finally putting
some font on top of that.
When you turn on your
profiler's overdraw mode,
you can see the
parts of your screen
that have been processed
the most times.
If your screen is super red
like this one down here,
then chances are you've
got performance problems.
Any work you do on a pixel
that doesn't contribute
to the final scene
is wasted work.
Now for 2D games, alpha blending
is the single biggest source
of overdraw.
Generally, a
majority of the scene
has to be rendered with
alpha blending turned on,
because those textures
use some geometry that
have an alpha channel
component in them.
When you render your objects in
your game with alpha turned on,
you're forced, forced to
render your scene in back
to front order.
This is because during each
draw, the alpha operation needs
existing pixels in the color
buffer to blend against,
which increases
the number of times
a given pixel on the
screen gets redrawn.
The truth is, the order in which
you draw your game geometry
has a profound impact on the
performance of your game.
In an ideal world,
what you want to do
is render all of
your opaque geometry
in front to back
order, which will
reduce the amount
of overdraw that
occurs, while rendering all
transparent geometry in back
to front order, which we're
forced to do anyway in order
to get the look we're after.
But this is easier said
than done, trust me.
I read an analysis of over
1,000 games from Google Play
and found the majority
of them are packing
both transparent and opaque
images into a single texture
atlas.
Typically, this is a bad idea.
Texture atlasing software
that's used to do this operation
doesn't always export the type
of per image information that
allows you to know what
was originally transparent
and what was originally opaque.
The result is that
you're forced to assume
everything in your
scene is transparent
and render everything in
front to back order regardless
of the performance
problems involved.
To fix this in your game,
it's actually pretty simple.
When creating your atlases,
split your alpha and opaque
objects into separate textures.
This will allow you at
run time to sort geometry
based on what type of
texture it has before
rendering them to
the final scene.
The new process will
help reduce overdraw
and will help make your
scene render faster.
Oh, and one more thing.
Once you've separated
your opaque textures
into their own atlas, make sure
that you properly compress them
with GP texture formats.
ETC, PVR, and DXT are
supported all by various levels
of hardware and will reduce
distribution and GPU residency
sizes of your textures,
which is something
everybody loves, right?
Anyway, the truth is
that you shouldn't
take alpha blending lightly.
Besides giving you the
look you're interested in,
there's a load of performance
issues you may not be aware of.
So think twice, alpha
once, and as always,
remember, perf matters.